CIRCLE IN THE PACIFIC OCEAN.
ERIC: CLAUDIA COWAN THANK YOU.
U.S. NAVAL SAILOR IN NAPLES
ITALY IS TESTED POSITIVE FOR
CORONAVIRUS MARKING THE FIRST
CONFIRMED CASE AMONG
SERVICEMEMBERS STATIONED IN
EUROPE.
THIS IS THE VIRUS CONTINUES TO
SPREAD RAPIDLY WORLDWIDE.
CHRIS TOMLINSON IS LIVE -- LUCAS
TOMLINSON IS LIVE.
REPORTER: ITALY IS PREPARED TO
LOCK DOWN PARTS OF THE COUNTRY
THE MOST DRASTIC ACTION YET TO
STOP THE SPREAD OF CORONAVIRUS
PRAYTOR COLLEY REPORTED IT WOULD
TAKE EFFECT TOMORROW.
MORE THAN 10 MILLION PEOPLE
AROUND MILAN WOULD BE AFFECTED
AND THE ARMY WOULD ENFORCE THE
QUARANTINE.
ITALY HAS NEARLY 6000
CORONAVIRUS CASES AND 230 PEOPLE
HAVE DIED FOR THE BIGGEST
OUTSIDE OF ASIA.
A U.S. NAVY SAILOR TESTED
POSITIVE 500 MILES AWAY FROM
ALONG.
FRIDAY U.S. MILITARY ANNOUNCES
FIRST CONFIRMED CASE
HEADQUARTERS FOR U.S. FORCES IN
KOREA AFTER SOUTH KOREAN
EMPLOYEE TESTED POSITIVE ON THE
BASE BUT THIS IS THE SEVENTH
CORONAVIRUS CASE CONFIRMED BY
THE US MILITARY IN KOREA BUT SO
FAR ONLY ONE ACTIVE-DUTY
AMERICAN SOLDIER AS 20,500
TROOPS BASED THERE HAD BEEN
AFFECTED.
MARK ESPER SAID IS FULLY
CONFIDENT THE PENTAGON CAN
WITHSTAND THE VIRUS.
>> WAY WE HAVE A LOT OF
CAPABILITIES AND IS BUILDING.
OUR COMMAND CENTER HAS THE
CAPABILITY GO FOR WEEKS AT A
TIME IF THEY HAD TO BE LOCKED
INSIDE THE BUILDING AND IF WE
HAVE SOME TYPE OF OPRY.
U.S. NAVY WARSHIPS CONTINUED
THEIR MISSIONS AROUND THE WORLD.
AFTER LEAVING THE AIRCRAFT WENT
TO VIETNAM THIS WEEK.
THEY SPEND 14 DAYS AS THE
FOLLOWING PROTOCOLS TO
QUARANTINE.
THE NAVY’S TOP ADMIRALS ARE
ASKED THIS QUESTION.
>> DO YOU HAVE TEST KITS?
>> NO, WE DON’T YET BUT THAT’S
NOT JUST A PROBLEM FOR DOD BUT I
THINK WE ARE GETTING TO A BETTER
PLACE IN TERMS OF THE PRODUCTION
TO ALLOW US TO BE ABLE TO
DISTRIBUTE THOSE TO THE FORCE.
REPORT TO THE HEAD OF INFECTIOUS
DISEASE AT WALTER REED MEDICAL
CENTER SAID THERE’S NO NEED TO
PANIC.
IN THAT WE SHOULD RECOGNIZE THAT
THE END OF THE DAY IT REMAINS A
LOW RISK TO NOT JUST OUR
SERVICEMEMBERS BUT THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC.
REPORTER: JON THERE TO CONFIRM
CORONAVIRUS CASES IN THE US
MILITARY OUT OF 1.3 MILLION
PEOPLE IN THE FORCES.